hi this is conan o'brien this is my
video response to taylor swift's
uh video
about her song 22.
i just watched it
taylor swift's great she's very popular
and she's very talented
but i know what it's like to be 22. i
don't think that that's an accurate
representation of what it's like to be
22. okay when you're 22 you're not
living in that apartment all right
you're living in a really crappy
380 dollar a month apartment in the mid
wilshire district in los angeles
i didn't see any ramen noodles in that
video because that's all you're eating
when you're 22.
when you're 22
the only reason you go out at night is
to watch st elmo's fire which is coming
out in the theaters and you're excited
because it's got your favorite actors in
it the brat pack
and you think it's really great it's
only until you're in your late 30s that
you realize it's really not a good movie
it doesn't hold up
i didn't see her driving a 1973 plymouth
valiant that she bought from from some
surfers in santa monica and you only
bought it because it had air
conditioning and the air conditioning
didn't work and the surfers laughed when
you left
i didn't see her having bad skin or
being way way too skinny
when you're 22 you you don't even go
outside there's nowhere to go there's no
one to talk to you don't have a
girlfriend people are like oh are you
6'4 and you've got orange hair who's got
orange hair what kind of name is conan
you're a freak so no one talks to you
you just sit in your apartment and you
watch save by the bell and you eat ramen
noodles and occasionally you spice it up
by having lucky charms you sit in your
boxer shorts and you learn guitar chords
by yourself
that's what it's like for everybody when
they're 22.
everybody
it's not that that's for sure
subscribe to my channel